well I mean I think us humans we're
pretty good it we're pretty good talking
about stuff just great but I'd like to
see more personal action and and i'm
really i'm talking from my talking to
myself here i mean i i've created this
great site and built this fantastic team
around it and i think that people should
focus on themselves and if people can do
the right things personally that can
have a tremendous impact and so we often
look to government or business or other
people to to do these things but i think
if we all spent more time looking to
ourselves it's really that simple i
think if we were if you were very vocal
with both our dollars terms of what what
products and services we're willing to
support and what not and in terms of the
political process i think that that in
itself can have a tremendous impact
because it also impacts the people
around you so it sort of covers the
consumer and the personal aspect sends a
message to business and sends a message
to to government so i think if we were a
lot more vocal and a lot less concerned
about what other people thought I think
when I think we'd be well on our way
really depends who you are answer what
what you've done I think a lot of people
what do they say a perfection is the
enemy of the good or something like that
I think a lot of people will put this
stuff off because they want to do the
right thing and I think logically the
way to approach your own personal
situation in terms of the environment is
to take some time to a carbon calculator
figure out where you have the most
impact focus on those things first etc I
think the challenge with that is that
people may put that off and put that off
because it's a big thing they just want
to do it right I want to be sure so I
try to cancel people just just get
started pick something it doesn't really
matter what pick something that matters
to you and it just feels right and just
start and I think that gets you on the
path and then you know if you want to be
more strategic great by all means get it
get on those carbon calculators figure
out where you can have your impact and
sort of do that so I think that's I
think that's it that's a big one I think
in terms of general concepts there's a
very very simple one just small is sexy
and it just apply it applies to ice age
ass but it applies to everything like we
just we have this perception that we
need a lot of things or volume or
what-have-you in order to be happy and
we just don't so whether it's
architecture you know the houses have
gone from some close to a thousand
square feet like 50 years ago to close
to two and a half so literally two and a
half times as big while the average
family size is shrunk it's not like we
are a lot happier now than we were in
the 50s so you can live a great life and
and you know in a much smaller home and
and by doing that because the space is
much smaller you you save on heating you
save on cooling you see save on lighting
you save on furnishing it just makes for
an overall simpler life so I think focus
on small small is great and that can be
cars that can be architecture that
me the size your wardrobe that can be
that your number of weekend jaunts your
plane I think just just focus on that
just sometimes to be analyzed